breaking just moments ago as first
reported by the New York Times the hills
John Solomon and now FoxNews have all
confirmed that the Attorney General bar
just appointed the US Attorney in
Connecticut to investigate the origins
of the witch-hunt into the Trump
campaign this is huge news
a colossal step forward for equal
justice and equal application under our
laws it's what we have been telling you
is big part of what is coming now if
you're counting this is now the third
investigation into the deep state taking
place in bars DOJ and you can add to
that Senator Lindsey Graham that will be
four investigations keep in mind Hoover
is also investigating the leaks out in
Utah the Inspector General Horowitz is
investigating FISA abuse and without a
doubt operation crossfire hurricane is
as we've been calling it operation
boomerang several days ago during a
series of important questions from
Senator Lindsey Graham to remind you he
asked the Attorney General about the
Muller report about what he viewed as
important we told you last week act to
the curtains about to go up tonight the
curtains up take a look
do you share my concerns about the FISA
warrant process yes do you share my
concerns about the counterintelligence
investigation how was opened and why it
was opened yes you share my concerns
that the professional lack of
professionalism in the Clinton email
investigations something we should all
look at yes do you expect to change your
mind about the bottom line conclusions
of the Moller report no do you think the
president's campaign in 2016 was
thoroughly looked at in terms of whether
or not they colluded with the Russians
yes and the answer is no according to
Bob Muller that's right he couldn't
decide about obstruction you did is that
correct that's right you feel good about
your decision absolutely
now while the Attorney General bar
searches for truth and justice and is
fulfilling what he said he would do
tonight hysteria spreading in every
corner of the Democratic Party as we now
enjoy
to the 2020 presidential election the
noise on the left is getting louder and
louder and louder but make no mistake
it's only noise nothing more it's not
based in any facts any truth any reality
we now have had over the course of two
years count them four separate
investigations that have cleared
president Trump the Trump campaign of
any type of collusion or obstruction
Democrats it's only noise they can't let
their own lies and conspiracy theories
go
but while the left continues to push
their hoax we have been uncovering what
is the biggest abuse of power scandal in
American history only we have evidence
in the end facts speak louder than
hysteria and tonight the facts are
casting a damning shadow on the
disgraced fired former FBI director
James Comey who is now being called out
publicly for by his former colleague of
all people rod Rosenstein in a major way
tonight look at this so I do not blame
the former director for being angry I
would be too if I were in his shoes but
now the former director seems to be
acting as a partisan pundit selling
books and earning speaking fees while
speculating about the strength of my
character and the fate of my immortal
soul I kid you not that is disappointing
Rosenstein unloading saying he broke
meaning call me lines that never should
have been crossed and rod Rosen Stein is
absolutely right to slam the former oil
disgraced FBI director Comey abused his
power the evidence against him is
mounting and here is what we now know
October 21st 2016 then FBI director
James Comey he signed off on the first
of what became for Pfizer warrant
applications requests against Trump
campaign associate Carter page denying
him his constitutional rights and more
importantly offering a backdoor into all
things the Trump campaign Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for dossier
according to the new Ness memo and the
Grassley graham memos the bulk of
information was the predicate for those
FISA applications they
unverified they were paid for by Hillary
they will put together by somebody that
hates Donald Trump and somebody who in
an interrogatory in Great Britain
actually said he has no idea of any of
its true 5050 it's just raw intelligence
that was the basis for a warrant not one
but four and call me signed the first
one it says on top of the warrant
verified the FISA Court was not informed
that Clinton paid for this well even
with the New York Times is suggesting
Russian disinformation instead James
Comey swore that the information that he
provided to the FISA Court and that
application was true and it was correct
the application itself mark verified at
the very top but the dossier was never
never verified frankly unverifiable
because Steele himself doesn't stand by
it
now during an interrogatory we told you
about in Great Britain that's when we
learned that truth and you know I don't
know if any if it's true but he was
under the threat of perjury at that
moment so we would expect that he didn't
want to tell the truth on that
Christopher Steele hated then-candidate
Trump he was willing to do anything to
take him down
DOJ official Bruce or was one of many
that we now know that warned the FBI
warned the department ajusted about
Steele's hyper-partisan conduct and
steals ties to the Clinton campaign well
before they October Pfizer requests the
or warning came in August of 2016 before
the October 2016 5 application last week
we learned also a high-ranking State
Department official named Kathleen
kavlock
well she also issued a direct warning
about Steele ten days before the FISA
requests she passed on the red flags
about Steel's election rigging efforts
the validity of his work and she sent it
to the FBI and the Department of Justice
they still went forward and used that
information anyway now Senator Lindsey
Graham he is working to declassify a
government document that he is saying
tonight will prove the FBI absolutely
positively knew that Steele's work was
full of lies and garbage and Hillary
paid for it by the way a lie by omission
in the case of the FISA Court abuse
they've literally conspired to
commit fraud on a court they hated
Donald Trump that much now we know
Senator Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson
they you should separate document
requests from the State Department and
the FBI in order to determine what call
me knew about steal when he signed off
on the warrant to spy on an American and
an opposition party candidate it's not
looking good for mr. super Patriot Jim
Comey and FISA abuse is just one part of
what is lawless behavior and abuse of
power
congressman Ratcliffe he is now calling
for an investigation into James Comey
tonight
take a look Jim's proud of himself but
the Inspector General found him
insubordinate and many of us believe
that he either is or should be under
investigation for violating the
Espionage Act for recording his
conversations with President Trump in
the Oval Office and then intentionally
leaking classified information to start
this investigation so you know Maria as
you know as a former federal prosecutor
I've worked with hundreds of FBI agents
and over the last two years they haven't
used the word proud once to describe Jim
Comey they use words like embarrassed
and ashamed let's not forget we're not
talking about the month with a single
premiere law enforcement agency in the
world single best intelligence agencies
in the world not the 99.9 percent but
the upper echelon they're the ones that
abuse their power the Jim Comey's of the
world self righteous super Patriot he
can do no wrong well he's in serious
trouble tonight we warned him many times
he has the right to remain silent he's
not listening to me doesn't matter how
many dramatic op-eds he writes for the
New York Times or how many long
infomercials he does with Anderson
Cooper over at fake News CNN he'll never
escape simple truth and facts he was a
terrible FBI director he abused his
power it's a good thing the president
fired him he we now know was involved in
rigging the investigation into Hillary
Clinton he engaged in a witch-hunt
against President Trump he anointed a
partisan corrupt group of bureaucrats to
his inner circle almost all of which got
fired resigned and disgraced or demoted
he
hopefully nuts misled and committed a
fraud it seems tonight on a FISA Court
to spy on the Trump campaign we know he
leaked sensitive government documents
it's against the law because he was mad
that he got fired and he leaked it to
the New York Times for the purpose of
getting a special counsel appointed and
now he is in Seigle serious legal
jeopardy James Comey tick-tock now with
the help of Sarah Carter John solemn and
so many others on this program well we
have always worked to hold unelected
powerful government officials
accountable the left is more interested
in scoring cheap political points
dividing the country and pushing
conspiracy theories with no evidence in
the Democratic control House of
Representatives they got people like the
cowardly ship at Nadler and company
trying to weaponize their committees why
to harass and order and prolong a series
of endless witch hunts into the Trump
administration now senator Graham has
documented their unprecedented behavior
take a look they just wanted outcome it
doesn't matter how you get Trump it
doesn't matter if you trick the FISA
Court it doesn't matter if you
infiltrate the campaign the goal is to
stop Trump and the rules don't matter
this is a very dangerous time in
American history where the media and the
Democratic Party wants an outcome
against Trump no matter what the rules
are doesn't matter they wanted to
destroy this president they didn't want
him elected they had a favored candidate
they rigged her investigation the
evidence is overwhelming it is
incontrovertible she had top-secret
classified information on a private
server and a mom-and-pop bathroom closet
and yes that's he illegal and yes she
tried to cover up the evidence by
destroying it that's why she in fact
deleted subpoenaed emails acid-washed
her hard drive with bleach pit busted up
her devices with hammers and removed SIM
cards why that was the intent to destroy
evidence the underlying crime Espionage
Act the Attorney General tonight
provided top Democrats access to all but
two full and seven partial lines of the
Muller report they're too lazy to go
look at it
this was grand jury information Nadler
scan
Mittie holding him in contempt demanding
that he he be handcuffed by the
sergeant-at-arms and brought before the
committee because he's obeying the laws
of the land and then he redacted in
accordance with federal law that's right
you cannot reveal grand jury material
that is the law of the land at least one
person understands it that would be the
Attorney General and because Barr
refused to break the law and reveal
grand jury information congressman
Nadler holding him in contempt they're
talking about putting him in handcuffs
calling the Attorney General's actions a
quote direct assault on the
constitutional order now many other
Democrats friends in the media mob
they're declaring that we are in the
middle of a constitutional crisis we've
been there for the longest time because
of those people that abuse power but of
course they've been pushing conspiracy
theories and lies and of course you got
the Intel chairman yes
the Cowardly shift yes it's downright
apoplectic losing his mind because well
the only person caught on tape colluding
with the Russians is him as he got fixed
up in a hoax oh do you have any evidence
on Donald Trump yeah we got evidence on
Donald Trump well what is the nature of
the evidence a naked pics of Trump naked
pictures I didn't plan a mere pool to
see it Vladimir of course but of course
he sees it really he's still eager to
defend Attorney General Eric Holder he
was held in contempt and of course in
that case Obama yeah he did invoke
executive privilege something throughout
the entire Muller investigation Donald
Trump never did he told everybody in the
White House to cooperate they handed
over 1.5 million documents and he
answered Muller's questions and still no
collusion for the fourth time we got
that that conclusion
anyway take a look at the cowardly shift
they seem they turned over almost the
entire Mullah report unredacted the
Attorney General William bar has
testified before the Senate Judiciary
Committee they're saying they're
prevented by a law from giving over this
grand jury information so what's the
difference here
there are categorical differences first
the Obama administration made dozens of
witnesses available the Congress
provided new
thousands of documents as you just heard
to the Republicans in Congress and yes
it made specific claims of privilege but
here the Trump administration has
decided to say a blanket no no to any
kind of oversight whatsoever no
witnesses no documents no nothing no
witnesses no documents no nothing yet
again the Cowardly shift is lying he is
a liar mr. Schiff come on this program
one full hour you and me I've got a
dossier on you it's called your own
words then come up my radio show for
three full hours you can bring Nadler
with you just for kicks and the full
molar report has been released the AG
has testified before Congress and Adam
Schiff is lying again he's like losing
it at this point but this kind of
far-fetched hysteria from the left is
not going unchecked as per usual
president Trump rightly now is fighting
back after four exonerations calling the
Democrats fake constitutional crisis
narrative pathetically untrue that is
true now the president is also calling
out the current FBI director Christopher
Rea accusing him of protecting the same
gang who tried to overthrow the duly
elected president of the United States
you know we smelly wall more people
irredeemable deplorable that cling to
God and guns and Bibles and religion
that's us so far I don't see director
raid frankly doing a darn thing to clean
up the upper echelon of this FBI that's
his job for the 99% of FBI special
agents that put their lives at risk for
us every single day you owe it to them
to get this department this premier law
enforcement agency right with the
American people what is Rea done to hold
call me accountable nothing what about
McCabe what about Baker what about
struck what about page mr. ray it's time
for you to do your job the former
highest-ranking employees in his Bureau
committed real crimes and yet no signs
that Ray seems to care one bit to bring
them to justice or working to prevent
this abuse of power hyper-partisan
conduct from ever ever happening again
but in the coming months justice will be
served we have promised you that with or
without
well director raised hell